what I've found is people that come out
years later why did you wait years I'll
give you guys like three months to come
out should we really take seriously
people that claim they were assaulted 10
years ago 15 years ago should there be a
cap on how long you can take to accuse
someone of assault and what is assault
you know I and I think this is what the
feminists do they change the definitions
of words
to make us more victims because they
just have this a narrative that men are
abusers men are evil and if you give men
power they're going to sexually assault
coerce rape whatever it is but then they
change the definition of those words to
include things like getting your butt
crap now I'm not saying that's okay or
not okay but like is that the same thing
as rape guys they don't include a lot of
the times that the women were flirting
too the women were playing into it